i'm michael knowles and this is the 1
000th episode of the michael knowles
show
do we have the technology to bring in
knolls from the room next door
oh my god my this is amazing this is
what will they think of you actually saw
a sausage party did you not i saw it so
that you don't have to do it you wrote
the famously insightful book
reasons to vote for democrats now the
president is being made fun of for
tweeting that it's a great read and this
is the first episode of our show can you
believe they gave me a show i think i'm
the first guy in history to get his own
show for not writing a book
things didn't go as planned inside
umkc's royal hall
this was a warning shot to conservatives
on colleges around the country i came to
hollywood like a million other idiots
looking for a break
instead one day i walked through a door
and found myself transported to a
lunatic fantasy kingdom i have got to
thank the listeners for
engaging with this show subscribing
leaving five star reviews and actually
bringing this show all the way up to the
number one podcast in the country
welcome back to the book club we're
talking with the great larry elder
douglas murray his excellency bishop
robert barron abigail schreier which is
why on crucial matters conservatives
have been left speechless i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
the confines of transmissibility now
going to be loosening up and broadening
them i would like to see a dramatic
diminution of the personal interaction
that we see whatever it takes to do that
that's what i'd like to see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you